this whole dragging you know
quote-unquote culture is just annoying
as [ __ ] like where we dragged the [ __ ]
out of somebody I was look look what it
becomes you know I was looking at this
video on Vice that was talking about
this I retreated it but it was like a
vice video that was talking about
colleges like Emerson and some other
college that nobody's ever [ __ ] heard
of that that they're talking about how
they couldn't they there and I've done
this dude I'm a comedian and I've had
colleges be like oh they want we want
you to do this show but you can't talk
about religion I say no I say no if I
could tell my agents to write in a
response go [ __ ] yourself I would but
they won't do that because they're mages
and they always go like I mean I've told
him to do [ __ ] like that and they're
like well you know I can't do it because
you know I keep the relationship no [ __ ]
that relationship dude if you're hiring
me to do stand-up the thing that I've
worked on for 12 [ __ ] years then you
get what I got dude I don't show up and
then adhere to your rules
I go I tell you to turn round and I grab
a handful II the back of your hair and
whoopsie I slipped inside yeah you got
royally [ __ ] um why college campuses
can be minefields for some comedians and
and you know what dude I take these gigs
and I and I and I and I and I I say
there's no rules no no restrictions
right my agents say none I go there and
I tell these [ __ ] college kids I do
the jokes and these college kids listen
and sometimes look the college kids
don't know what they believe yet so
everything is almost offensive because
they haven't figured themselves out yet
and that's fine dude when I was their
age I didn't know myself either I didn't
know myself till yesterday okay but when
you're a stand-up
comedian and you're up there and you're
coming to my show you're not gonna get
[ __ ] offended and if you do you're
getting I'm visually [ __ ] you that's
it you're dude that's it you don't get
to be offended these are jokes period
when I fall oh dude I had a Stephen
Hawking joke and he died and I was like
well I'm still gonna do the joke just
cuz he died I'm still gonna do the joke
now when I do the joke everyone oh I'll
[ __ ] you dude
shut up it's a joke so I was watching
this thing on Vice on Vice and it was
talking about Emerson was one of the
colleges and to other colleges that
nobody ever [ __ ] heard of and they
were like oh you know we don't want them
to be you know colleges are more diverse
than ever so they can't make transphobic
jokes they can't make jokes about rape
they can't make jokes about sexual
assault if they're more diverse than
ever then why are they all thinking the
same goddamn thing ah you mean they're
not diverse cuz you mean they're more
diverse because they're different colors
kiss my [ __ ] ass they're all thinking
the same thing hello we're welcome hello
one ticket for the comedy show yeah
hello we have a group of four with the
[ __ ] light red light across the mouth
you know you know hello
four tickets to a comedy show how are we
are programmed to laugh at the things
that are not offensive yeah we all agree
because we are all on the same network
oh gods comments sitting comments
laughter mode welcome comedian hey guys
what's going on ha ha ha so the pink n'
isn't just for girls
ha ha a guy can wear pink too yah yah
yah yah yah
meh I agree I was programmed to agree we
are all program Tory laughs in unison
yeah
what a beautiful comedy show well well
hello guys I'm the comedian for tonight
you can be you can be a man or a woman
whether you can having sex look there's
so much I don't know about it
sex isn't gender uh-huh that's like
saying peanut butter is jelly oh my god
this is the most hilarious comedian I've
ever heard in my life yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah must tweet
about how great he is anyone who opposes
will be dragged thanks for coming out
everyone
whoo we had a great time here at the
most liberal ascribe a bee is [ __ ]
College of all time it's called cry-baby
you well I am so happy to get my diploma
at a crybaby you I am so happy to be
here everyone please welcome the
valedictorian of snowflake of state of
state snowflake state university hello
hello students now you will embark on to
the real world yeah III III oh yeah yeah
yeah yes we will let you know that the
real world can be tough out there some
people think that you don't think don't
really care what you think oh wow that
really can take the sail out of your out
of your the wind out of your sails
autocorrect wind out of your sails but
it's okay the real world those people
will be in jail because you cannot speak
out against what is liberal otherwise
people will go to jail and we basically
live in the 12th century now yes nenene
mean there is that problem is that the
one name that's everyone receiving their
diplomas
Scot is the same not the same noise that
when when you watch the [ __ ] horns
and the and the girls are getting are
getting tight you ever see the porn
where they're like on the gynecology
[ __ ] chair and the [ __ ] big robot
arm [ __ ] them and it's like Scott who's
watching that only really fat guys and
really skinny guys watch that you can't
have a regular body and watch that [ __ ]
do you have to be like really frail and
you're like oh or you're like with four
watch some more get [ __ ] by robot arms
and there's just so fat and you eat the
food on your belly it's big guys a
rubber dildo
and then it goes faster it's like it
goes just like like turn it off II why
are you in a dungeon always cuz it's
wrong hey if you're in a dungeon what
you're doing is wrong the lower you get
the worse you are if you're on the
[ __ ] also if you're CEO of a company
you're probably evil too and you're on
the top floor and get somewhere in the
middle how about everyone remains on the
ground that's that's it that's when
you're [ __ ] morally okay it's God's
Nene it's gay thank you so much I am
prepared for live now yeah do it just so
[ __ ] like I don't know I don't
understand why liberals don't don't get
that what they're doing
is only going to make it worse for them
and what they believe pretty soon
they're gonna be on the end of of
because it's like it's like everybody is
offended nobody's offended and
everything is funny until it's offensive
to you you know what I mean and that's
[Music]
hello students I would like to prepare
you to the for the real world if you are
black and somebody says something
negative about you or if you are white
and and somebody says something negative
about you or if you are a Asian and
somebody says something negative about
you they will be fired and dragged
across the social coals of injustice
[Music]
also you can be fired for breathing
wrong
[Music]
you can remember America is a place
where you can say whatever you want
until it doesn't jive with the community
[Music]
remember America so many hydraulics
[Laughter]
well you're American you may say
whatever it is you please unless it
doesn't jailer the community or also
doesn't speak to a fringe bro
[Music]
[Applause]
you are now prepared to embark on the
real world and remember hook up to our
system so you know how to feel if you're
unsure of how to feel please sign in to
the Wi-Fi snowflake and the and the
password is cry-baby remember we all
think the same and if we don't you will
be executed now now it is time for the
after graduation party here we go a time
for the graduation party
god damn [ __ ] yes here we go wait a
minute was there to the N world that was
the N word must find eg Caledon pump him
and then [ __ ] him and kill him I don't
even know what I'm talking about anymore
I mean you know I'm so hood you know I'm
so hood a man hands it across my neck
and it's Imran said I mix my neck ah
that bit I did it way too long but
whatever dude that's what you get that's
like my dad do it my dad I'll [ __ ]
take a bit and run it in the ground
that's why I get it